thank you any conflicts or interests
[Applause]
[Music]
we have a fairly short agenda we will
take trevor as a deputation and we may
change the word deputation to his normal
uh reporter
just to keep things in order
if everybody's happy
just a short powerpoint presentation
some of you that were at the martin
community this morning
so really just a brief update on
district improvements
is at the moment it's a case of steady
as it goes in terms of engagement and
feedback we are
a month into a 43 day
submission period and we highly expect
most of the
submissions and any queries around
information will come in those last
couple of weeks but particularly last
week that's certainly been the case
in other jurisdictions or new
descriptions
just in terms of a few statistics
you can see on the left-hand side there
that we've
noted at least 142 notification
sort of enquiries asking bits and bobs
about the different different aspects of
the plan and they're broken down into
how they've been recorded as well
today on the right hand side there's
been 16 submissions received so 16
formal submissions
and twelve of them being to buy the the
e-plane submission module and the other
one hard copies and there's a number a
number that's sitting in the e-claim
submissions module which are draft more
meaning that people have registered or
gone in there and have crafted something
up but they haven't hit the submitted
button yet to us so there's more on
their way
also on there is a number of uh furthers
of public awareness schools to occur
over the over the submission period
which runs through to the 26th of
november
and there's four of those listed here as
well
obviously we do need to be covered aware
and one or two have been changed over
the course of
october and we just try to try to do our
best in terms of
making sure to reschedule another time
[Applause]
uh looks appreciated you probably can't
read too much on this there's basically
we grasp that out here from uh sarah
mcfadden and the comms team
this is regarding the website over the
last
month
you can see in the right-hand corner top
right corner talks about highlights 1
visits to the website i've watched
there's 299
deeper dives so that's the more informed
visitors
and apologies you can't see the blue box
in the right-hand corner but all those
it gives you a breakdown of what people
have gone and looked at which includes a
video
downloaded documents such as the summary
document or the faq's document
or have visited multiple project pages
it's
282 on there as well so look quite
modest numbers at the moment
but
we expect that to continue over the next
month
or so
particularly near at the end of the
submission process as i said
uh look i won't blow on this one
on too much this is just some of the new
news for the banner in particular that
runs around the top
um
it's it's had a little bit of attention
as well
uh look we'll continue to keep up the
communications package through all the
channels that were in that
communications plan
that includes uh drop in and talk to
planners every day at the wrangler or a
service center
there is
an event tonight in tomorrow night at
kaivoy
from 6 pm until 8 pm there's an oxford
all event coming up as well followed by
some more
and there's also the odd bespoke
engagement event as well such as at
mandible and any other place
by and large the main way is to get a
hold of us through the website through
the phone through the email and then we
can talk to people through those
channels as well
so that's really largely it just
submission uh
so that's largely it when it comes to
that i'll take any questions
trevor wants for me to start just just
around the code in
rescheduling some of those is it does
they need to be publicized
a length of time do we need to be
stretching the actual time out or are
they going to fit into that
and into the period comfortably that
we've got out for the consultation some
of the early events i think uh a little
bit earlier in terms of the male coming
out that's what you mean but some of the
later events are shifted later in the
submission from the period
we can only react to covert if we change
the level then we'll have to go to more
online means in terms of engagement but
i think we're doing as best we can when
it comes to different events around
managing code and distancing license
it is very difficult to do that
i hope that answers your question thank
you any further questions uh
[Applause]
thanks trevor um the public awareness
sessions how have you found those
to be working
and have you had much
engagement with people as a result of
those
no they
they are passing by type needs um really
so um they are another opportunity just
to wave the district plan better
arguably they're not particularly
effective or arguably not
simply to say i've found the talk of
planner events very effective the ones
i've been to so far
uh certainly modern rengura was very
well attended
um
really well intended so
i think the way that that's been managed
audrey with that intro system and then
feedback
is working well
the drop in minds on
public awareness one least convinced
they're
we're having them um in particular the
pegasus area there was some concern
right he wasn't
though so thank you for picking that up
and addressing it um because
in ravens with those communities we're
quite um sensitive to those we're having
events there so thank you for uh
addressing that but the engagement we've
heard at
[Music]
we're trying to do better than we need
to in terms of
all the options available technically
industry to put our public medicine and
send it to all great days we've done
problem service we've written great
players
we've um written to uh occupiers and
then there's all these other above and
beyond mechanisms some more effective
than others
and sending ideas to trucking the
message out there as much as we can to
enable solutions to be made
so we'll continue to do that through the
26th of november
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you trevor thank you very
much
thank you very much
[Applause]
all right one of 6.1
met
pages 14-17
um take the reporter's read off just run
you through the main
issues in the paper um so to start with
um you've seen in the report that um
consent numbers are significantly up
this year
which has obviously been a response to
people's awareness that the district
plan is going to be notified soon so our
numbers are well up um now that the plan
has been notified we are expecting a bit
of a drop-off
and we'll have to see how that plays out
over the next couple of months
but early indications and other numbers
are down
so
this month to date in october we've had
17 consents received and looking back on
the last of six months or so the average
number that we've had previously we
would have been expecting to have around
about 30 by now so yeah the implications
are that the numbers are down
and the type of consents as well
there's certainly been a significant
drop off in rural subdivision
applications
so yeah there's changing what's coming
through the door for us
um so although the consent numbers seem
to be dropping um we have a little
backlog to get through
from prior notification and we're
working through those at the moment um
the other thing is we are extremely busy
on the duty planner front
it have been really for the last six
months or so
lots of inquiries coming in and they are
taking longer to deal with this is a
part because they just tend to be quite
complex there's also the new district
plan to deal with now um i know trevor
put up some figures about the number of
inquiries that his team had had and
pou are also supposed to be entering all
of our enquiries but talking to the
planners they are so busy they're simply
not doing that um or not always so
they're getting about 20 to 30
enquiries by email or phone or at the
counter every day to deal with
as well as the other
duty planner responsibilities as well
so
it's also following through into our
compliance and monitoring area they are
extremely busy too
and you will have seemed to signal that
there may be a need for additional
resources in that area going forward
because obviously it's all part of the
same
process at the end of the day
and as well as if you go down to the
financial occupations part of the report
that reflects in the income coming in so
we're about 300 000 over budget
however we've also got increased costs
both in terms of staff time and we've
been using a number of consultants
for all of this year to help us deal
with the numbers of consents we've had
in so those two things really balance
out at the end of the day
there's some detail in the report about
individual significant consensus but um
i mean i'm open to questions if anybody
has anything in particular but i think
they're feeling um well covered in the
report i guess the message
quite strongly as we busy um but the the
wider implications of that is that that
means that there is a lot happening out
in the community there's a lot of
development going on which is a good
thing
um so that's that's it
thank you
i think it's a good summary
questions yes
very good report i see you are rushed
off your feet
i was just curious though on your um
1.4 you talk about
um service requests 220 related
overhanging trees was that all just
lately and was it that i guess my
question behind behind that was was that
um
perhaps in conjunction with the snaps in
seoul campaign or what or was it
throughout the year
uh sure so i think that's an um
throughout the year and just to note
that's the calendar year and so some of
us that sometimes we do financial year
and sometimes do calendar
and yes that has gone uh it has
increased quite significantly because of
snapseed solved um and also just two
when
compliance staff are out and they see an
issue that needs to be dealt with
they'll log it as an issue and you deal
with it right there too so
sometimes it's not a call that's come
into us to resolve it it's just
something we've picked up when we put it
through the recruitment system
thanks just wondering what impact that
might have happened
thank
you
any further questions
appear to be number any recommendations
and what you have to do
move to the council regimen secretary
council of duty councillor
uh just thank you we need a very
comprehensive report
so it's good to know that the numbers
are up on last year but you're actually
coping and that the unit is fully
staffed
at a time when it is difficult to get
started so um you're in a very good
space thank you
counselor
any other
speakers
thank you very much
[Applause]
we should no i don't know you're right
i'll put that
all those papers
[Applause]
thank you good afternoon
so we've prepared the report for
information to you and i'll take it as
read um we do did have kind of a
random statistics that we threw in here
just as a brief snapshot of the unit
um
as you can see most of our service
requests and number of dogs and dog
registrations and
um licensing and everything has just
turned up a little bit it's not
extremely far up it's just kind of in
line with the population growing and
just increased
um
demands on our services up in general
uh as for a second capability we are
currently in the process of hiring an
esu team leader um we have filled the
eso administrator our goal which has
been wonderful to get back in the house
and so we're gradually transitioning
some of the workload that we've been
outsourcing to contractors back in-house
as well
does anybody have any specific questions
about
any part of this report
any questions
from the report
just in general and
uh what systems are we in place i guess
perhaps
it's a very difficult um
matter to address and find these issues
but we've we've gotta we seem to be
getting a few more hours back to the
track compared to other
uh seasons if we consider that
i haven't looked into that specifically
it can do um as far as what i'm hearing
from the team is that
this is just kind of par for the course
so it doesn't seem to be too outside of
normal we have implemented a um
substantiated box a substantiated box on
a service request so that when we do get
a complaint we can go out and monitor
and then we can note whether it's we've
actually found that there is working or
not
you prefer me to leave michael on or
turn him off
he was just working that kind of yes
it's just a year or so
that's fine
um
i think there have been a number of
cases so the the dark blocking is a
little bit subjective but by the dot
control act it does have to be loud and
persistent for us to act on
um if it is not resistant and they my
officers do hear the barking they will
approach the owner and talk to them
regardless and just give them a heads up
what's going on but many cases will go
out there and there may not be any
working at all
um so we are trying to track that
substantiated unsubstantiated kind of
claim system is a new process so we have
just implemented
two months ago so
um
great thank you
for the question councilman
just
regarding that do you think there's a
bit of a need of an education of our
community
[Music]
that's certainly a good suggestion i
don't know how well it would be received
i think
part of the numbers being
high
is affected by lockdown so more people
being home and hearing it and then also
you've got more people at home with
their dogs and they may not be barking
but when people go back to work then
dogs are anxiety almost off a little
ways and they're
often working more
so there's a little bit of both sides of
that coin before during walk down an
hour then you might get a little bit of
increased
[Music]
this is a very important team and i
appreciate all the work that you do it's
a difficult area and and
i certainly know the noting the increase
of dogs in industry and a large
population of dogs particularly in our
industry
but we have seen um i haven't had as
many complaints recently actually
personally
um about dangerous or menacing that
swirling so i think that's nice to hear
that we're getting on top of that the
barking and nothing's always going to
happen
if i could just make one note perhaps
that the word licensing um should have
an estimate and be consistent through
the document that would be really good
going forward thank you
apologies for submitting the new zealand
americans
you may have just got this one you've
got quote
and just to acknowledge i am getting as
you're probably aware through my office
um
i'm more about
dog barking issues and i that's all i
i'm appreciative for how that and
watched that followed up because they
are subjugated often increasingly having
people recording them now
and
getting those through but i know that
when i think through that being followed
up
i'm very impressed with the team and how
they're operating
in general
and those sort of things too
um certainly
uh people are appreciative
that there are
both sides of it um they've got the
enforcement um
you don't like that but then there's the
retailers in our towns that do prefer
that so we have people here so
the team is performing really well thank
you for your report
thank you we you seem to have a number
of um residents who are not satisfied
when we do not hear from our hands
we're trying to stay on top of them
you've done a good job
just a question on the food licensing
how do we get on when uh with combat you
know sometimes
they have to be shut down and can't
use can't do their free licensing is
there anything that we can
[Music]
how do you deal with that
um we're more involved in the compliance
and licensing side of it so we are able
to do as i said in the report um
we outsource this to a contractor who
does have remote verification and
capabilities so they are able to
continue the verification process to
make sure everybody's licensed up to
date and their food
but as for offsetting operating costs
we don't get involved in the operating
side of the food businesses
i just wanted to say
that um
thank you for the efficient and
professional way that you handle
your portfolio of things that that our
team works with because i know
personally just since
lockdown that you know we've had
had a lot of
issues with
dog problems and
the turn dumping and along stop banks
and things and i really appreciate the
quick and effective way that you've
dealt with those in the professional
manner that you've dealt with people
involved as well
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
updates
the question about people whose
applications are all trained
thank you mr chair
um
one or two methods
to mention
we had a
hearing for dangerous and affected and
unsanitary buildings
uh last week and that went very well
councillor dodi and barney were on the
panel with me
and the interesting thing was
that you would expect an earthquake
damaged building
to have
to come under the dangerous category but
in actual fact
earthquake damage buildings are
specifically exploded
from um this part of building acting and
our policy
the affected building is a building next
door
to a dangerous
building so
the recommendation will be coming to
council and we recommend that
this information be included on limbs
there's some discussion about that but i
think the consensus was that it being
included so
that will probably be coming to council
next month i think
um
and i understand staff facilitated
between muscle car maintenance
organizers and neighbours in the police
um last week to discuss concerns
regarding the event
and
for more accounts that was dynamic or
meeting with some good outcomes
and really it comes down to
communicating with people before the
problem arises properly
staff are working on a compliance
framework to ensure compliance
monitoring and enforcement are carried
out fairly and consistently across the
council
and we're going to have a briefing on
that in november
and the other thing that we've talked
about the gambling policy
that's been moved out for the first
quarter of next year
to avoid potential consultation fatigue
obviously
a very serious condition at this time of
the year
in the interim
the policy team are thinking about
making a short voluntary survey
available to gather views on gambling
to help them inform the review next year
and um
there were some emails recently about
the minister of civil defense wanting to
come and visit us uh the new minister is
kiri allen
and because of other commitments i think
that's been put out until election
thank you for those reports i have no
questions my urgent general business the
next meeting is
included in the agenda here so i declare
the meeting closed
which is the council of lakers
information we didn't need
okay